it pains me to admit that I'm still
renovating my kitchen
and I always say
you can't renovate without making a mess
literally everywhere else
so today I'm tackling some very dirty and very overdue job
starting with my fridge
so I'm going in with the JIF Cleanboost Cream Cleanser
in the new scent Lily Flower
the Cleanboost range is more demure
made with naturally derived cleaning ingredients
and a biodegradable fragrance
onto the veggie bins and I'm dealing with what looks like
it would have been a great starter culture for my compost
I do love compost just not in my fridge
and this one looks like it was moments away from becoming sentient
if I thought the fridge was bad
the bins were so much worse
I used some more JIF to scrub the inside and the outside
within an inch of its life
which did wonders for my mental health
and even though it's designed to be safer for people and the planet
you still get that really powerful JIF clean
with no residue left behind
with the bins reset and smelling fresh
it was time to turn my attention back to my poor sink
which has just taken an absolute beating this entire time
I gave her a good scrub
while whispering my apologies for the
trauma that I've just put her through
and just like that the holy trinity of domestic bliss
aka the fridge bins and sink
are done